le retour sur la scène française de
touré kunda le groupe sénégalais des
années 80 qu'on est au départ quatre
frères puis trois aujourd'hui
deux d'entre eux perpétue le métissage
de son rock et de sang africain
il était cette semaine à l'affice du new
morning à paris
jean françois sauvé lé frère ismaïl les
six coups tidiane touré ont été les
pionniers de la musique africaine en
france à la fin des années 70 m à cette
chanson était l'un de leurs premiers
tubes
après quelques années de succès on les
avait un peu perdu
si j'avais arrêté on a fait beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de tours mais il ya
deux ans on a fait une tournée avec un
carrosse en tenant à travers le monde
on est passé à bercy mais il n'ya pas
aucun point médiatique ni la presse ni
le quoi que ce soit
pour les paroles il utilise différents
dialectes le sonic et leur langue
maternelle mais aussi le mandingue et le
wolof il faut ainsi découvrir un nouveau
public
les racines de l'afrique profonde et la
musique fait le reste
il ya une génération à l'époque l'idée
light n'est pas la même actuellement la
qui a besoin de découvrir surtout cette
génération qui vient d'afrique et qui
est né ici
en attendant leur nouvel album une
compilation de leurs meilleures chansons
vient de sortir et ils sont actuellement
en tournée dans toute la france jusqu'à
la mi juillet